oK we've been following this flip-flop
over the the Muslim ban deportation
flip-flop that Donald Trump has been
involved in and Katrina Pierson Trump
spokeswoman is now in the midst of this
immigration flip-flop in an absolutely
glorious and majestic way Donald Trump's
spokespeople
are a truly fascinating Bunch and that
often they're unable or refused to speak
for the person they were hired to speak
for some of Katrina Pearson's greatest
hits include defending the Muslim ban by
saying so what after all we're only
talking about Muslims here she showed up
on CNN wearing a bullet necklace she
defended Trump's call for a pure-breed
president she explained that she really
couldn't explain the immigrant band
proposal because we haven't yet heard
the full story from Donald Trump as to
what it would even be and most recently
she blamed President Obama for a
soldier's death in 2004 of course Donald
a President Obama rather was not
president until 2009 and also claimed
that President Obama invaded Afghanistan
when he did not she has now come up with
a completely I have no better way to
describe it than kafka esque way to
explain away how Donald Trump has been
running for months on deporting all
undocumented immigrants and then all of
a sudden last week changed his mind on
it he since now apparently come back to
the deportation plan or maybe not we'll
get to that in a second Katrina Pierson
showed up on CNN and said no no no no no
Donald Trump's position hasn't changed
he's now just using different words to
discuss the topic which of course led to
the entire CNN panel erupting into
laughter take a look
Katrina how do you square those two he
said very specifically yes he's gonna
still be the woman he said and I'm
quoting I just want to follow the law
we'll work with them that's a big change
well first let me let me correct the
record first Donald Trump did go to the
community in the primary it was in March
and it was in Chicago so I hope that CNN
continues to correct that narrative
moving forward by saying that he's never
even tried to go to the community
because he has and secondly he hasn't
changed his position on immigration he's
changed the work that he is
saying what he has always been to be
done to achieve that he does not that he
know that he does not want to allow
people to stay in this country illegally
he does want to build the wall but he
wants to work just that ten feet shorter
that and that's exactly what he has said
from the beginning Katrina he has said
get them out it has been very clear
about his position this is a change this
is a shift this is a flip-flop it's an
evolution whatever word you want to use
America it's the how that's being
discussed now he's always said if
they're here illegally they have to go
here before a deportation force so now
he is shifting Katrina there is a
definite different message that we're
hearing now there's not a different
message he's using different words to
give that message because everyone on
the news is saying that he's a bigot and
that he's a racist because of the words
that he uses now he said different words
don't have different meanings I mean in
Katrina Pearson's world words no longer
have meaning the message is the same no
matter what words you use Your Honor my
client did not steal anything he
persuaded others to give him these items
by showing a firearm and implying that
he would use it on them if they didn't
comply in Katrina Pearson's defense
Jayson this is not exactly an easy job
that she has it's a fine line words
aren't messages messages aren't words
they're very different things clearly
this is Sarah Palin 2.0 and I as crazy
as we've seen Katrina Pierson be some
part of me feels a little bit bad for
her because there is no explaining when
you're a spokesperson for someone whose
speech cannot possibly be explained in a
rational way you're not necessarily
going to be able to make lemonade out of
half of a rotten lemon I think is sort
of the best analogy that I can imagine
here I've talked about how people of all
ages but particularly Millennials are
owning cars less and participating more
in the sharing economy and one of the
more popular options is Zipcar which
gets you a car when you want it when you
need it they offer all sorts of cars
SUVs hybrids whatever you need it
includes insurance and it includes gas
you just pay for the time that you
actually use the car and you can reserve
the car online for
your smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zip card each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1600
pounds per year for our audience
Zipcar is offering $25 a free driving
credit if you sign up at join zip car
comm slash david support our show reduce
your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zip car
comm slash David